I like the new wave of feminine crime
fiction writers who are feminist but not
in this you pitch politically correct
way they're Semin ISM is an authentic
feminism you know they don't have this
patronizing attitude like you know women
women should always be passive victims
and so on and so on but even maybe now I
will say something for it maybe will not
be popular here even better than her she
called Gillian Flynn or what is an Irish
girl called Tana French a series of kind
fiction taking place in Dublin with more
or less the same spirit the same
attitude a kind of a if I have to invent
some stupid title a kind of a dark neo
feminist
crime thrillers but not of the of the
movie that I recently thought there is a
problem often a movie attracts me
not attracts me but gives me to think
intellectually but I don't really like
it as a movie for example the one her
with your him well you know in the film
at the end he is the hero together with
a girl I think she is called Amy but
they are both abandoned by their
machines
the big enigma here is and this is what
always attracted me and this is I think
what my mentor in theory French
psychoanalyst Jacques Lacan in this that
in his crazy thesis there is no sexual
relationship which means we are never
alone me and my partner there has to be
a third element a fantasy scene an
intruder it's only through that
mediation of a third element here in her
their operating systems that sex
function and then I started to think
about other variations of this like for
a perfect day intelligently made 20
years old British publicity for beer
which is a wonderful ironic repetition
of an old fairy tale motive you know a
young girl walks by a stream
she's a frog and of course that's what
you do in fairytales she picks up and
kisses the frog and the Frog turns into
a prince charming young men but then the
publicity goes on the charming young man
looks at her kisses her and she turns
into a can of beer you know like that's
what he really wanted you know and then
I found here in the stage a similar but
inverted versions some pretty disgusting
is mentally publicity for Taco Bell
publicity for something called quesarito
which is Casa Delia and burrito
combination of the tools and it's
presented in such an obscene way that if
you combine the two it's really like a
penis in wrapped by a vagina but how is
the publicity spot done here's a young
guy in the girl seat during lunch break
at the table one has just a Delia the
other burrito and they look at each
other and then you see each person's
dream boy looks at her and imagines the
future they start to talk they get
married have children then she looks at
him approaches him in her dream and take
this piece of burrito or whatever rap
skip ups that she gets a kind of a
bisexual completing and just makes a
sign and he disappears you know it's
similar to that reverse but what I think
is that the Enigma behind all this is
why do we never get just a couple why it
always have to be some intruders and the
best Hollywood version of this I asked
all the viewers who are watching us now
to
to download you can download it for free
it's an American classic movies preston
sturges lady eve where you have the
ultimate marriage proposal scene you
have Henry Fonda and Barbara Stanwyck
and a horse standing behind them and the
horses head is always intruding and so
on and so on there is the mystery of sex
it's never too you always need something
and imagined gaze and element intruding
and so on and so on